[Music]
things get emotional on and off screen
as netflix dropped the final episodes of
stranger things season four
and we feel like we're in the upside
down as the normally chipper actor noah
schnapp tears up irl check out the actor
who plays will in the sci-fi thriller
holding his head with tears streaming
down his face he captioned the pic happy
stranger things finale
major spoiler alert ahead fans have been
waiting for answers after this scene
where will and mike have a
heart-to-heart about 11 being different
it's just she's so
different from other people and
when you're
when you're different
sometimes
you feel like a mistake
but you make her feel like she's not a
mistake at all like she's better for
being different
and that gives her the courage to fight
on if she was mean to you or she seemed
like she was pushing you away it's
probably just because she's scared of
losing you just like you're scared of
losing her
it's a scene in episode 8 that leads to
more questions in the next one the
season finale alluding to will's sexual
orientation and him having unrequited
feelings for his friend mike you paint
this
yeah
yeah i mean i mean i mean l
asked me too she commissioned it
basically i mean she told me what to
draw
but the big question is will seemingly
coming out as queer if she was going to
lose you i i think she'd rather just get
it over with quick like ripping off a
band-aid
so yeah
elle needs you mike and she always will
jonathan played by charlie heaton seemed
to clue in on will's emotional response
in the pep talk as if will was speaking
from experience about being different
but it's the finale where will's brother
tells him he loves him no matter what
that has stranger things fans on the
fence about the less than explicit
coming out moment
and i'll always be here
no matter what
because you're my brother
and i love you
there is nothing in this world okay
absolutely nothing
that will ever change that
you got that
yeah
and and i'm always
here for you too i know
e.t sat down with noah and his castmates
charlie heaton and eduardo franco back
in may with will sort of struggling to
get into high school and watching elle
struggle and then on top of that having
his best friend maybe not
feel like his best friend anymore will's
definitely in kind of an uncomfortable
situation and all he wants is just to be
back to normal with his little friends
in the basement will's like a very
protective brother for elf
come
here everyone's here
[Music]
[Music]
as for will sexuality creators the
duffer brothers may reveal more in
stranger things season 5.
[Music]
you